ils vont avec c'est seconde lecture au
terme de la discussion de ce projet de
loi je voudrais donc remercier bien
évidemment le président de la commission
des lois
les membres de commission des lois son
président jean jacques hyest le
rapporteur jean-patrick courtois les
présidents des groupes de la majorité
qui ont permis d'aboutir à ce texte qui
est à la fois équilibré et ambitieux et
je remercie philippe richert de mini des
collectivités territoriales d'être là
alors c'est un fait nous acheminons pour
la huitième année consécutive vers une
baisse de la délinquance dans notre pays
ces résultats naturellement nous ne les
deux vont pas au hasard nous les devons
à la mobilisation des policiers les
gendarmes au partenariat qui ont été
établis avec les élus locaux et les
acteurs de la sécurité partenariat qui
sont nombreux et efficaces pour autant
la délinquance évolue et donc elle se
transforme en permanence et face à ces
évolutions face à ces transformations
nous devons nous adapter nous devons
nous renouveler pour cette bataille
acharnée qui est menée contre les
fauteurs de troubles et trafiquants et
les voyants et l'adaptation c'est le
sens de ce projet de loi d'orientation
et de programmation que je vous présente
donc en deuxième lecture aujourd'hui
alors largement enrichie grâce à vos
travaux
ce projet contient des dispositions
essentielles qui moderniseront les
moyens opérationnels des forces de
sécurité intérieure adapterons encore la
réponse pénale créeront de nouvelles
réponses ciblées audi enfance formes de
la délinquance et développeront les
partenariats utiles à la sécurité de nos
compatriotes nous obtenons dont d'avoir
première inflexion des résultats contre
l'insécurité je veux pas rentrer dans le
détail nous
j'aurai l'occasion de présenter les
résultats dans les prochains jours sur
l'ensemble de l'année mais d'ores et
déjà les chiffres des 11 premiers mois
montrent les résultats obtenus les
avancées qui ont été permises puisque la
délinquance sur les onze premiers mois
de l'année et par rapport aux premiers
mois de l'année 2009 la délinquance le
bal recul de plus de 2% ça signifie une
chose très simple très simple sur
laquelle je pense que nous devrions tous
nous réjouir c'est que sur l'année 2010
sur l'un des derniers encore
l'insécurité à reculer dans notre pays
et donc la sécurité a progressé au delà
de ces résultats encourageants que je
présenterai dans mes de détails non plus
dans quelques jours il reste c'est vrai
de vrai défi à relever auquel je suis
particulièrement attentif je pense
d'abord et aux atteintes volontaires à
l'intégrité physique
l'augmentation c'est vrai a été divisé
par cinq
mais cela reste cela demeure le grand
défi de nos sociétés modernes et la
france n'y échappe et à cet examen à cet
égard d un exemple des vols de
téléphones portables sont très
révélateurs les vols de téléphones
portables ont augmenté de près de 40 %
sur les onze premiers mois de l'année
2010 et grâce au blocage des téléphones
portables et leurs cartes sim qui est
prévu juridiquement et techniquement
nous allons progressivement j'en suis
convaincu rendre de tels
sans intérêt pour les revendeurs comme c
était le cas d'air il ya quelques années
chacun s'en souvient m'ont donné pour
les autoradios où on a modifié les
dispositifs et donc c'était un peu moins
intéressant moi j'appartiens à une
génération quand j'étais étudiant et ici
on m'a volé je ne sais pas quand une
fois au moins en tout cas trois fois
l'auto radio dans la voiture aujourd'hui
ce sont des types de délinquance qui ont
subsisté encore un peu mais qui ont été
disparu pour des raisons que je suis
persuadé que concernant les vols de
téléphones portables
nous allons évoluer dans ce sens alors
pour relever un certain nombre de défis
de ces défis il ya il existe une feuille
de route d'en fixer une feuille de route
que nous appliquons très méthodiquement
qui permet à la fois cibler notre action
d' adapter nos méthodes et consacrer nos
moyens sur l'essentiel rien certains ont
de plan opérationnel que les mises en
place depuis plusieurs mois avec un
principe simple dès qu'un problème est
identifié nous devons adopter une
stratégie ciblée pour une réponse qui
soit la plus appropriée c'est ce qu'on a
fait pour les cambriolages c'est ce
qu'on fait pour les trafics de
stupéfiants pour la protection des
personnes âgées ou des personnes
vulnérables d'ailleurs plus largement
les personnes âgées pour la lutte contre
les bandes pour les violences scolaires
contre les hooligans
et pour lutter contre l'insécurité dans
les transports je récapitule tout cela
même si les résultats sont à l'évidence
inégaux selon selon les secteurs
alors parallèlement nous adaptons en
permanence nos méthodes de travail
c'est l'enjeu de la police
d'agglomération celles qui existent sur
les trois départements de la petite
couronne et paris depuis septembre 2009
et nous allons étendre cette police
d'agglomération et vert
lille lyon marseille et peut-être même
d'ailleurs bordeaux au cours des
prochains mois et c'est aussi notre
volonté surtout notre capacité parce que
la volonté à vrai dire beaucoup
l'avaient notre capacité à franchir
progressivement efforts de sécurité d'un
certain nombre de ce qu'on appelle les
charges indues et qui détournaient les
policiers les gendarmes de leur coeur de
métier et concrètement en trois ans ce
sont pas moins de 1000 gendarmes et
policiers qui vont être remobiliser sur
des sur le terrain c'est le cas d'air
depuis le 1er janvier
donc ça commençait à se mettre en place
puis 1er janvier pour la police des
audiences qui peut être assuré par des
sociétés privées ou des réservistes de
la police et la gendarmerie qui sont
rémunérés et équipé par me sert la
justice pas dire dès qu'il faut pas que
les forces de police ou de gendarmerie
soient présentes il peut y avoir des cas
très précis dans lesquelles il ya des
risques naturellement il faut s'adapter
mais le principe c'est aurait un fait
qui est ces policiers ces gendarmes la
police d'audience forcément sur le
terrain
et puis s'il ya nécessité on peut
naturellement les mobiliser sur les
trois ans à venir
les transfèrements pénitentiaires seront
progressivement prise en charge par n'y
sert la justice là aussi c'est une
attente qui est une attente ancien
marché très sensible
l'attitude très positif de la
chancellerie sur ce sur ce point et puis
je précise c'est pas quantitativement
majeur mais en face et aussi même
d'abord ça existe et puis ses symboles y
la place vendôme prendra désormais
progressivement à sa charge la garde
statique de ces locaux étaient effectués
aujourd'hui par les gendarmes
et il y aura d'autres allègements qui
sont possibles notamment au palais de
justice de paris
en tout cas c'est une c'est une attente
qui est une attente qui était fort
beaucoup d'entre vous le sam qui suit
ces questions et je pense qu'on a bien
discuté bien avancé bien négocié au
cours des derniers mois de l'année 2010
pour y parvenir
alors si nous prenons des mesures que
nous souhaitons les plus efficaces pour
assurer la protection de nos
compatriotes dans et les ja part au vote
en première lecture et nos âmes or ce
combat contre la délinquance ont été
plus que significativement renforcée je
veux pas revenir dans le détail sur ces
nombreuses dispositions qui font déjà
l'objet d'un accord entre les deux
assemblées
il ya encore quelques précisions et
d'actionnaires qui reste en débat et ont
été concrètement la loppsi améliore
significativement nos moyens d'action
dans quatre domaines
premièrement domaine et outils
opérationnels de la police et de la
gendarmerie qui sont modernisés je pense
à la vidéoprotection je persiste à dire
que c'est un outil majeur de prévention
de dissuasion et dit lucide à sion s'il
y en a qui ne sont pas d'accord
surtout qu'il le dise il soit qu'ils ne
soient pas silencieux il
faut le dire parce que comme ça on
comprendra mieux quelles sont les
différences entre les uns et les autres
et je pense que l' équilibre qui est sûr
le contrôle la vidéoprotection et qu'il
trouvait avec l'assemblée nationale me
paraît très adapté d'un côté il y a
la commission nationale de la
vidéoprotection qui conseillera le
gouvernement et de l'autre la cnil
associés aux commissions départementales
pourra proposer au préfet des sanctions
au cas de manquement ray qui sont fixées
par les autorisations d'exploiter des
camions de plus il y aura des logiciels
de rapprochement judiciaire qui
amélioreront la rapidité des enquêtes et
qui feront notamment progressé
l'élucidation par exemple des vols en
série
parallèlement la lutte contre la
pédopornographie sera renforcée pourra y
revenir la lutte contre le terrorisme la
criminalité organisée sera facilitée
avec des outils modernes qui doit l
outil qui doit être à la hauteur de
certaines organisations criminelles
je pense aux captation de données
informatiques aussi la patrie institut
deuxième domaine c'est la sanction
pénale qui renforcer les fonctions des
sanctions j'y tiens tout
particulièrement seront aggravées en cas
de cambriolages et de vols au préjudice
d'une personne vulnérable
c'est à dire une personne âgée qui
seraient des difficultés plus grandes
difficultés pour se défend c'est le cas
aussi naturellement des handicapés ça
peut être le cas des femmes enceintes
toutes les personnes dites vulnérables
dans le même sens ailleurs les biens
saisis appartenant aux trafiquants
pourront soit être vendus soit affectée
aux forces de sécurité
et je pense que c'est un moyen
pour les services de police de faire
armes égales avec les délinquants par
exemple en saisissant leur véhicules
surpuissants
ils pourront traquer d'autres mais
évidemment un motorisation égale à ce
pas dire qu'on est totalement démunis on
sait très bien par exemple certaines
voitures aujourd'hui de la gendarmerie
qui sont des subaru ont joué ces deux
marchés qui avaient été remportées très
bizarrement aucun constructeur européen
à l'époque d'ailleurs s'étaient
manifestés pour répondre à cet appel
d'offres enfin on sait très bien que bon
les trafiquants certains noms ce que
j'appelle les go-fast bénéficient de ces
bolides ses véhicu bon c'est quand même
beaucoup mieux si on arrive à les saisir
puis les réaffecter choix les ventes
soient les réaffecter aux forces de
sécurité
de la même manière la vente à la
sauvette deviendra un délit spécifique
qui permet et sera mieux réprimer
enfin des mesures vigoureuses son conte
seront prises afin de renforcer la
sécurité de nos concitoyens qui prennent
les transports en commun et j'ajoute
d'ailleurs je vais évoquer je crois
devant la commission des lois que comme
me l'avait demandé le président à hisser
le 16 je suis attaché très attaché à la
possibilité donnée aux agents des
compagnies de transport chargé de la
sécurité possibilité ne conduit à eux
mêmes des délinquantes devant un
officier de police judiciaire et je
soutiens donc totalement et l'amendement
présenté dans ce sens par jacques
gauthier en troisième domaine les moyens
de la police administrative sont
complétés pour renforcer la prévention
et la dissuasion dissuasion
incontestablement nous avons pu rendre
les stades aux familles on sait très
bien qu'elles étaient les dérives assez
localiser pas simplement d'ailleurs à
paris en région parisienne et
les mesures qui sont contenues dans le
projet de loi permettront de conforter
et d'améliorer les résultats déjà
obtenus
ça c'est pas des formules c'est pas des
se sont pas des slogans et vous souvenez
certainement quand c'était le crois de
28 février 2009 deux en 2010 pendant 28
février 2010 il y avait eu un mort au
parc des princes
à la suite de combats on avait pris des
lendemains des mesures immédiates
création d'une division anti-hooligans à
certains deux ont été on a résolu je
peux toujours l'enterrement du bois on a
résolu je pense pour l'essentiel mais
malheureusement toujours y avoir un
contre exemple on a résolu pour
l'essentiel la question à l'intérieur
des stades
il faut davantage sécurisée l'extérieur
destin parce que naturellement ça a
tendance à s'effacer mais il n'en reste
pas moins ils vous l'avez certainement
vu dans des reportages dont il est lui
en tout cas sur les 20 heures où des
familles lisait on peut enfin revenir en
famille profiter d'un spectacle d'un
spectacle sportif
nous avons donné aussi aux possibilités
aux préfets la possibilité d'instituer
sur un territoire donné
entre 23 heures et 6 heures du matin un
couvre-feu des mineurs de moins de 13
ans cette mesure est utile je pensais
peut jurer nécessaire et c'est aussi un
moyen de prévenir la délinquance des
mineurs
et comme j'ai d'ailleurs déjà précise en
première lecture nous donnons aussi aux
préfets la possibilité de confisquer
immédiatement le véhicule des
délinquants de la route afin de mettre
hors d'état de nuire un certain nombre
d'irresponsables
enfin quatrième domaine la sécurité
c'est d'abord la mission de l'état mais
c'est aussi la sphère de tous nous
paierons prenons de proposons des
mesures pour renforcer les partenariats
partenariat avec les élus locaux puisque
les prérogatives des polices municipales
sont renforcés en complémentarité avec
la police et la gendarmerie partenariat
avec les acteurs
de la sécurité privée et pour
accompagner leur développement il faut
naturellement c'est un secteur qui est
en pleine évolution devra certainement
l'occasion dû revenir bras je rappelle
quand même on est tous soucieux de
l'emploi je rappelle quand même que le
syndicat national des entreprises de
sécurité prévoit un recrutement de plus
de cent mille personnes sur les dix
prochaines années une semaine on était
douze mille par an était quelque chose
comme ça mais enfin cent mille personnes
vont être recrutées donc naturellement
ça signifie qu'il faut bien l'exigence
la contrepartie ça signifie il faut près
qu'il faut être précis sur la
réglementation sur les autorisations sur
les délivrance d'agrément qui les
possibilités de retrait d'agrément mais
en tout cas il faut qu'on aille un petit
peu plus loin et la loppsi le père mais
puisqu'on proposent la création d'un
conseil national de la sécurité privée
qui permettrait de répondre à tout cela
alors tous et toutes ses dispositions
déjà fait l'objet d'un débat de fond je
pense que l'on doit aller encore plus
loin dans la lutte contre les violences
aux personnes
et c'est à l'évidence ce que nos
compatriotes attendent de nous et nous
avons souhaité proposer dans la loppsi
re parfaite harmonie avec la
chancellerie 80 jours nouvelles
spécifiques et simule première mesure
c'est le placement sous surveillance
électronique alors sorti de prison des
multi récidivistes condamnés à au moins
cinq ans d'emprisonnement dans ce qui
n'est pas rien et je remercie d'ailleurs
la commission des lois d'avoir donné
depuis l'origine son plein accord sur
cette mesure deuxième mesure j'ai bien
compris la position de la commission des
loi sur les peines planchers un accord
de principe a été trouvé entre les deux
assemblées en première lecture qui
conforte la volonté lui avant
d'appliquer ces peines planchers aux
primo délinquants et non plus
aux seuls récidivistes et c'est une
évolution majeure que le président de la
pluie qui avait d'ailleurs est évoqué et
souhaité dans son discours de grenoble
il y ait un débat technique y demeurent
sur les modalités et la portée de cette
évolution et je pense qu'il est tout à
fait opportun est il que nous
établissions gradation ces peines pour
les violences aggravées il serait donc
très attentifs à vos propositions et
j'ai noté d'ailleurs l'intérêt que
présente à cet égard l'amendement de
christian et de zinc dans certaines
occasions d'y revenir
troisième mesure je suis très heureux
que le sénat ait d approuver l'idée de
permettre à la cour d'assises d'assortir
son verdict de condamnation à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
s'agissant des crimes et délits à
l'encontre commis à l'encontre des
agents dépositaires de l'autorité
publique donc condamnation avec une
période de sûreté de 30 ans là aussi ça
s'inscrit dans ce cas souhaité plaisir
de la république à grenoble
il est vrai qu'une nuance subsistent
entre les deux assemblées
à la différence de l'assemblée nationale
et du sénat et du gouvernement le sénat
a souhaité que cette mesure soit
restreinte aux seuls de ces crimes qui
ont été commis en bande organisée ou
avec la circonstance aggravante de
guet-apens de guet-apens de
préméditation
encore une fois je pense ma position la
position du gouvernement c'est que que
le crime ait été commis par un individu
seul ou en bande organisée la peine
de sûreté devrait s'appliquer la gravité
des crimes qui sont mis en cause
rappelle senneurs de policiers de
gendarmes de préfet de magistrats deux
pompiers exige que l'on se montrent
particulièrement inflexibles
quatrième mesure qui concerne la
possibilité de faire comparaître un
mineur plus rapidement devant tribunal
pour enfants je le dis moi le système
actuel et doit être à l'évidence
améliorée et aujourd'hui en effet dans
un certain nombre de cas cette prise en
charge est presque totalement
improductive
parce qu'en réalité trop tardive on sait
très bien que le délai important qui
sépare trop souvent la commission de
l'infraction du jugement contribue au
sentiment d'impunité est réduit à quasi
néant les efforts de pédagogie et de
prévention de la récidive qui doit être
véritablement au coeur de la prise en
charge des mineurs
et c'est pourquoi dans les affaires les
plus simples et pour les mineures je ne
précise bien déjà connu de la justice
le gouvernement souhaite donner aux
procureurs la capacité de saisir
directement le tribunal sans passer par
le juge des enfants
cette nouvelle procédure qui encore une
fois je le rappelle qui est préparé
étroitement avec la chancellerie
cela s'appliquera uniquement uniquement
lorsque le mineur est déjà connu de la
justice et que tous les éléments
concernant sa personnalité pour parler
clair son environnement familial sont
déjà connus là aussi c'est un des
éléments d'efficacité de notre politique
de prévention
quelques mots simplement pour terminer
sur le permis à points on doit pas
perdre de vue l'essentiel
l'objectif c'est de faire blesser de
faire baisser
pardon le nombre de morts comme le
nombre de blessés est sur les routes de
notre pays j'imagine
on est tous d'accord je rappelle quand
même qu'alors que la population a évolué
il a près de quarante ans nous
déplorions près de 18 villes morts sur
les routes par 18 me en 2000 nous en
étions encore à quasiment 8200 tuées
selon l'observatoire national a terminé
à l'insécurité routière en 2010 nous
sommes passés sous la barre des 4000 on
est très certainement à exactement 3
1994 c'est beaucoup moins naturellement
qu'il ya dix ans comme je le rappelle
mais c'est encore beaucoup trop
alors c'est vrai que le gouvernement
n'avait pas proposé et je me tourne
peut-être davantage vers la majorité
c'est vrai que le gouvernement n'avait
pas proposé d'évolution sur le permis à
points les parlementaires du sénat comme
ceux de l'assemblée nationale ont
souhaité la sont assouplies et
conformément au souhait du sénat le
délai de récupération des petites
infractions entraînant la perte d'un
seul point serait réduit d'un an à six
mois est le délai de récupération de la
totalité des points passerait donc de à
deux ans au lieu de trois actuellement
mais le gouvernement souhaite clairement
qu'en soit exclu les infractions les
plus graves que ça soit les conduites en
état d'ivresse
que ça soit les grands excès de vitesse
comme des infractions qui sont des
infractions dangereuse par exemple on
sait on l'entend d'ailleurs vous lisez
chacun journaux et jaune
malheureusement des exemples est
quelqu'un qui a fait demi-tour sur une
autoroute enfin bref on a tous ces
exemples et donc sans une infraction
très dangereuse pour lequel précisément
les dispositifs de je dirais de clémence
ne le sont pas
approprié donc je vous le dis il est
impératif de ne pas aller au delà de
cette évolution et toute manière en tout
état de cause nous devrons évaluer le
moment venu les effets voilà monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs mesdames et
messieurs sénateurs monsieur le
rapporteur la mission qui a été confiée
qui m'a été confiée par le président
appuie les prémices très clair c'est
assurer la sécurité de nos concitoyens
partout et pour tous
alors nous avons des exigences nous
fixons des objectifs nous obtenons un
certain nombre de résultats pour
renforcer la sécurité dans le respect
des libertés
mais encore une fois pour pérenniser
conforter et amplifier ces résultats
nous devons en permanence nous adapter
et c'est ce que nous proposons à travers
ce projet de loi la loppsi à et déjà été
débattu durant plus de 70 heures à la 72
heures à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat
il y est incontestablement quelques
étapes à franchir et je suis
naturellement pour y parvenir à la fois
à votre écoute
en espérant naturellement aussi pouvoir
compter sur votre soutien je vous
remercie les filles
dans la discussion générale en paroles
et à jean patrick courtois rapporteur de
la commission des lois
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues nous
débutons aujourd'hui l'examen en seconde
lecture du projet de loi d'orientation
et de programmation pour la performance
de la sécurité intérieure dite loppsi 2
après sur second examen par l'assemblée
nationale au cours du mois de décembre
évidemment de nombreuses dispositions
font à ce stade l'objet d'un accord
entre nos deux assemblées
concernant d'abord l'encadrement des
fichiers d'antécédents judiciaires et de
la listeria
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas apporté de
modifications de fond au dispositif
adopté par ses dents il va également
ainsi de la plus grande partie des
dispositions relatives à la
vidéosurveillance figurant à l'article
je vous rappelle qu'alors que le projet
de loi déposé par le gouvernement
attribuer le contrôle dispositif aux
commissions départementales et à coller
commission nationale de la
vidéoprotection
le sénat avait introduit la cnil dans le
dispositif estimant que son expérience
en matière de libertés publiques l'a
qualifié en la matière cette
modification a été globalement approuvé
par l'assemblée nationale
de même une partie non négligeable du
chapitre relatif la sécurité quotidienne
et à la prévention de délinquance
introduit par l'assemblée nationale
avait été en grande partie approuvé par
le sénat et n'a pas été modifié de
manière sensible par l'assemblée
nationale en seconde lecture
c'est le cas des dispositions relatives
au couvre-feu de portée générale décidée
par le préfet pour des mineurs de 13 ans
ou encore de celle concernant le
règlement intérieur qui encadrera les
échanges d'informations au sein des
groupes de travail des clspd
le sénat avait également adopté en
termes identiques ou avec des
modifications d'ordre rédactionnelles
la plupart des articles relatives à la
sécurité routière
l'assemblée nationale n'a pas opéré de
nouvelles modifications substantielles
sauf pour un article qu'il s'agit des
dispositions relatives au permis à
points
introduite par notre collègue alain
fouché initialement le délai de
récupération de la totalité des points
du permis et est abaissé à un an au lieu
de trois ans la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale a décidé d'opter
une position intermédiaire
en portant ce délai à deux ans en séance
publique
un nouvel amendement est adopté qui
introduit une exception pour les délits
routiers les contraventions les plus
graves
pour ces infractions le délai restera
fixé à trois ans par ailleurs
l'assemblée a accru les possibilités de
faire des stages de récupération de
poids au total ces dispositions paru
équilibré à la commission des lois qui
n'a pas souhaité les modifier une
nouvelle fois le sénat avait par
ailleurs globalement donné son accord
aux dispositions introduites par la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale relative à la police
municipale
il avait ainsi approuvé l'attribution de
la qualité d'appel j au directeur police
municipale
la participation des policiers
municipaux contrôlent identité sous
l'autorité d'un au pgi ou encore la
simplification des règles d'agrément
pour les agents de police municipale
le sénat avait également étendu le champ
d'application des dispositions prévoyant
la participation des policiers
municipaux dépistage d'alcoolémie
l'assemblée nationale n'a apporté en
seconde lecture que des amendements
rédactionnels ses articles enfin de
nombreuses dispositions introduites par
le sénat à l'initiative du gouvernement
ont été approuvés par l'assemblée
nationale
c'est le cas des mesures destinées à
lutter contre les violences dans les
stades ou dans les transports
sur ce dernier point toutefois la
commission a supprimé une disposition
introduite par l'assemblée nationale en
seconde lecture et qui déséquilibrait
les règles relatives aux contrôles
d'identité fixées par le code de
procédure pénale nous aimons toutefois
l'assemblée nationale est également
profondément amendé certaines
dispositions introduites par le sénat
ou refuser les modifications apportées
par notre haute assemblée aux
dispositifs qu'elle avait introduit
ainsi lors de l'examen du projet de loi
par le sénat en séance publique le
gouvernement avait souhaité que les
dispositifs des peines plancher soit
étendue aux primo délinquants auteurs de
violences aggravées ou de délits commis
avec la circonstance aggravante de
violence notre commission s'y était
opposé considérant notamment que ce
dispositif présenté à risque de
contrariété à la constitution elle avait
également à cette occasion réaffirmé son
attachement à la cohérence de l'échelle
des peines ainsi qu'au pouvoir
d'appréciation des juges
pour ces raisons nous avions émis un
avis défavorable à l'amendement du
gouvernement sensible à ces arguments
nos collègues gérard longuet jacques
gauthier avait proposé sous-amendé
l'amendement du gouvernement afin de
limiter son champ aux violences les plus
graves
le dispositif ainsi sous-amendé avait
été adopté par le sénat en seconde
lecture les députés sont largement
revenus au dispositif initialement
souhaitée par le gouvernement et l'ont
même étendu un certain nombre
d'infractions supplémentaires comme les
violences sans circonstances aggravantes
en outre s'agissant des conditions dans
lesquelles les peines à six proposée
pour être pourrait être aménagé les
députés ont adopté un amendement de leur
commission des loi tendant à revenir au
droit antérieur à la loi pénitentiaire
du 24 novembre 2009 qui a posé le
principe de l'aménagement des peines
égales ou inférieures à deux ans
d'emprisonnement dans la mesure où cet
article présenté en l'état un risque
d'inconstitutionnalité qu'ils faisaient
de l'emprisonnement des mineurs la règle
dans le nombreux cas et qu'il remettait
en cause certains principes essentiels
de la loi pénitentiaire alors même que
les décrets d'application de ce texte
est toujours d'être adopté votre
commission des lois est revenu au texte
voté par le sénat en première lecture
lesquels réserve la possibilité de
prononcer une peine plancher aux seuls
auteurs des violences les plus graves
l'assemblée nationale a également
souhaité revenir aux dispositions
proposées par le gouvernement relatives
à la possibilité de poursuivre un mineur
devant le tribunal pour enfants par la
voix d'une convocation par au pgi en
première lecture
ces dispositions ont été rejetées par
notre commission et n'avait été adoptée
par le sénat que complété par un
sous-amendement qui avaient restreint
leur champ d'application
compte tenu du retour opéré par
l'assemblée nationale aux propositions
rejetées par la commission des lois
celle ci est également revenue au texte
voté par le sénat enfin concernant
l'article 23 ter relatifs à
l'allongement de la peine de sûreté pour
les auteurs du meurtre ou d'assassinât
contre les pots stone dépositaire de
l'autorité publique
les députés sont revenus à la rédaction
proposée initialement par le
gouvernement
en effet les dispositions introduites
par celle par celui ci avait été sous
amendé par le président jean jacques
hyest gérard longuet et nicolas about
afin que comme tel est le cas pour les
meurtres ou assassinats concernant les
mineurs de
quinze ans l'allongement de la peine de
sûreté ne vise que les crimes
accompagnés d'une circonstance
aggravante il était ainsi précisé que le
maire devait être commis en bande
organisée ou avec guet-apens
l'assemblée nationale ayant écarté toute
référence est une circonstance
aggravante la commission des lois est
revenu au texte du sénat en première
lecture en retenant toutefois la
préméditation comme circonstance
aggravante
enfin d'autres désaccords entre nos deux
assemblées porte ce dispositions
relatives à la sécurité quotidienne
les députés ont ainsi rétabli les
dispositions qu'ils avaient introduite
en première lecture
concernant la possibilité pour le préfet
de décider d'un couvre feu à l'encontre
d'un mineur déjà condamnés ou relatives
à l'information du présent du conseil
général et du préfet par le procureur de
la république sur les poursuites et les
condamnations dont font l'objet des
mineurs dans le département dans la
mesure où ces dispositions présentait un
risque d'inconstitutionnalité et
semblait en août d'application très
difficile
la commission des lois est revenue au
texte du sénat par ailleurs les députés
ont introduit deux dispositions
totalement nouvelle la première étant la
prescriptive bilité au crime se
traduisant par une disparition d'enfant
la seconde vise à singulariser la
situation des étrangers reconnus
coupables d'un crime en contraignant les
jurés des cours d'assises à se prononcer
sur l'ordre aux séjours dans le respect
des limitations édictées par la loi du
26 novembre 2003 dans la mesure où elle
considère qu'il est préférable de
réserver le caractère exceptionnel de
l'imprescriptibilité aux crimes contre
l'humanité et où le droit positif permet
d'ores et déjà de répondre largement aux
préoccupations des auteurs de
l'amendement
la commission a supprimé la disposition
qui étend l'imprescriptibilité au crime
se traduisant par une disparition
d'enfant
voici tracé mes chers collègues les
grands axes des modifications adoptées
par la commission des lois pour la
seconde lecture de ce projet que je vous
demande mes chers collègues d'adopter
merci monsieur le rapporteur dans la
suite de discussions générales la parole
est à jacques mézard pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
d'abord j'ai écouté avec intérêt va seul
ministre nous parler des statistiques et
je constate qu'il n'y a pratiquement
beaucoup moins de délinquance et que
mais bientôt vous allez rechercher à ce
rythme là les délinquants entre le titre
d'un texte législatif et son contenu
réel le fossé devient souvent de plus en
plus évidents les loi de simplification
sont devenues des lois de
complexification qu'en est il des loi
d'orientation et de programmation pour
la performance de la sécurité intérieure
nombreux sont ceux qui constatent que le
projet de loi qui nous est soumis
constitue un fourre tout où se
retrouvent pêle-mêle des dispositions
diverses correspondant pour beaucoup à
des réponses médiatique à des faits
divers
c'est d'ailleurs ainsi que récemment un
quotidien a pu titrer quand les faits
divers dictent leur loi
certes il serait absurde et dommageable
pour la protection de la société de ne
pas être très attentif à ce qui se passe
sur le terrain dans nos rues nos sites
et nos campagnes de ne pas intégrer
l'évolution de la délinquance
consécutive aux bouleversements
sociétaux
mes chers collègues la réponse
législative a défait médiatisé est tout
aussi dangereuse et dommageable car elle
est créatrice d'insécurité juridique et
ces dernières années nous y sommes
pleinement confrontés elle est le plus
souvent à l'opposé de la définition
d'une véritable politique pénale
compréhensible par le citoyen est
facilement applicables par les
magistrats
nous le savons tous ici dans cette
enceinte
les magistrats sont excédés par cette
avalanche de loi dite sécuritaire
qui polluent littéralement le difficile
exercice de leurs missions
la priorité du législateur c'est d'abord
me semble t'il d'examiner si les lois
existantes permettent tout nom de
répondre aux préoccupations du moment et
aux évolutions sociétales bien sûr
lorsqu'il s'agit de cybercriminalité le
socle du code d'instruction criminelle
de 1810 ne saurait suffire mais nombre
de réformes de textes accumulées ces
dernières décennies fürth inutiles
parfois redondants et largement sans
efficacité si ce n'est à des fins de
communication politique est là encore
avec quelles conséquences redoutables
vous jouer aux apprentis sorciers et
faudra-t-il souvent rappelé les propos
du nouveau président d'honneur d'un
parti à l'extrême de l'échiquier
politique les électeurs préféreront
toujours l'original à la copie
monsieur le ministre je l' ai déjà dit
lors de l'examen du texte en première
lecture
je ne doute aucunement de vos sentiments
républicains mais je reste convaincu que
les sens des textes que vous nous
proposez n'est ni de nature à rassurer
les français ni à faciliter réellement
le travail de ceux qui oeuvrent à
préserver leur sécurité
nous avons dénoncé les errements de la
garde à vue
nous avions raison le garde des sceaux
lui même aujourd'hui déclare qu'il
serait bien d'en réduire le nombre de à
300 milles car on ne lutte pas contre
l'insécurité en jouant sur le sentiment
d'insécurité
de la même manière ce n'est pas la
réduction des effectifs de police et de
gendarmerie qui constitue la bonne
méthode
le procès de la police de proximité fut
un mauvais procès une erreur
ce n'est pas avec 16 loi sécurité en
huit ans que l'on construira un code de
procédure pénale performant nous sommes
dans une discussion générale
il est donc justifié d'avoir un débat de
fond
de même qu'il serait justifié d'avoir un
débat sur la manière dont est traité la
question de la délinquance financière
sous ses diverses formes qui pèse de
tout son poids dans le sentiment
d'insécurité assez généralisé
d'injustice dont découlent certains
comportements antisociaux en première
lecture puis par le travail de sa
commission et de son rapporteur le sénat
a fait entendre son souci du respect de
principes fondamentaux auxquels nous
sommes tous attachés ici et nous nous
réjouissons de cela le message de la
majorité de l'assemblée nationale est
différent et c'est son droit mais la
majorité de notre groupe ne saurait
cautionner ce message et je cite pour
mémoire l'orateur de la majorité à
l'assemblée message de fermeté à l'égard
d'une délinquance sans scrupules qui
fait régner la terreur
nous aurons appris qu'il y avait deux
formes de délinquance avec et sans
scrupules y c'est déjà un progrès mais
plus sérieusement nous considérons qu'il
ya erreur de diagnostic et erreurs
thérapeutique faire croire au laxisme
des magistrats est fallacieux et ce
n'est pas en augmentant le quantum des
peines constamment que vous ferez
progresser la sécurité
s'il existe une crise de confiance à
l'intérieur de la police de la
gendarmerie de la justice
les lois successives que nous avons vécu
depuis ces dernières années ne l'auront
aucunement atténuée bien au contraire
cela étant rappelé on ne peut que
constater et déplorer que l'assemblée
nationale ait rajouté une couche dans le
sécuritaire
ce n'est pas sans raison que plusieurs
organes de presse noter que le texte
était devenu le véhicule législatif des
mesures sécuritaires annoncées cet été
par le président de la république
il s'agit donc d'un texte réactionnelle
ce qui c'est vrai n'a pas le même sens
que réactionnaire je vous la corde dans
l'intérêt général
il convient de tempérer le texte qui
nous vient de l'assemblée nationale sur
la vidéoprotection qui n'est pas la
panacée quand même au niveau de la
sécurité même si ça peut constituer un
progrès dans certains cas
l'article 17 étend les possibilités
d'installation et des usages sur la voie
publique à des personnes morales de
droit privé après simple information du
maire le sénat avait prévu que la cnil
pouvait exercer un contrôle des systèmes
installés
l'assemblée nationale a refusé que le
contrôle puisse selon les principes de
la loi informatique et libertés se
réaliser et à supprimer la possibilité
pour la cnil qui avait été introduite
par le sénat de mettre en demeure un
responsable de traitement de faire
cesser un manquement et de prononcer un
avertissement public
ces dispositions mes chers collègues son
contraire à la jurisprudence
administrative
j'espère que la position du sénat
l'emportera l'article 23 bis introduit
au sénat contre l'avis de la commission
étant aux primo délinquants auteurs de
violences volontaires le dispositif des
peines plancher qui ne sont à l'heure
actuelle jusqu'ici applicable qu'en cas
de récidive
si le sénat avait limité son champ aux
violences les plus graves
puni de dix ans d'emprisonnement ayant
entraîné une incapacité temporaire de
travail supérieure à quinze jours
l'assemblée nationale a considérablement
étendu le champ de l'article est aussi à
supprimer le principe d'aménagement des
peines inférieures ou égales à deux ans
d'emprisonnement posées par la loi
et ans hier le durcissement du
dispositif pose naturellement la
question de la logique poursuivie dès
lors que la prison demeure un facteur de
récidive et que ne sont pas réunies
aujourd'hui les conditions permettant de
véritablement permettre la réinsertion
des détenus
ce que tout le monde sait se pose
également la constitutionnalité du
dispositif puisque le conseil
constitutionnel ça a d'ailleurs été
rappelés dans le rapport de notre
collègue courtois n'avait validé en 2007
le principe de la peine plancher qu'en
raison de la condition de récidive
légale
l'article 23 ter introduit au sénat sur
proposition du gouvernement allonge la
période de sûreté pour les auteurs de
meurtres ou assassinats contre les
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique
notre assemblée avait subordonné ce
dispositif à l'existence d'une
circonstance aggravante disposition
supprimée par l'assemblée nationale
l'article 23 qu'un pièce étend le champ
d'application de la surveillance
judiciaire aux personnes condamnées à
une peine d'emprisonnement d'une durée
supérieure ou égale à cinq ans en état
de nouvelle récidive et l'article 23
sexy s prévoient de recourir à une
procédure de convocation par un officier
de police judiciaire à l'encontre d'un
mineur ce qui est pour le moment
impossible est interdite on peut d'abord
s'étonner d'une telle disposition
alors que la chancellerie travaille
aujourd'hui sur une réforme globale du
droit pénal des mineurs
l'article 24 bis instauré un couvre feu
pour mineurs y compris au niveau
individuel le sénat considérant les
risques juridiques toujours important
avait introduit le recours au juge
l'assemblée nationale une fois de plus
est revenu sur cette disposition alors
que s'agissant d'une sanction
cette dernière relève du juge et non de
l'autorité administrative
cette dérive je viens cette dérive est
particulièrement inquiétante
de même que peut noter au passage la
volonté d'aller à l'imprescriptibilité
pour certains crimes visés à l'article
24 15 pièces en fait de la période de
sûreté aux peines planchers et bientôt
aux jurés populaires en correctionnelle
il s'agit en fait d'une illustration
constante d'une méfiance devenue
systématique
j'allais dire épidermique à l'égard de
la magistrature
ce qui est grave le plus souvent injuste
et ne peut que perturber l'équilibré
fragilisés de nos institutions
oui monsieur le ministre messieurs les
ministres vont auriez tort de rester
sourd aux discours du procureur général
près la cour de cassation le 7 janvier
je les lui intégralement
je me doute qu'il ne vous à points fait
plaisir il a dit afficher pour la
justice une sorte de mépris inspirer à
l'opinion des sentiments bas en
instillant de manière en réalité
extravagante la confusion entre la
responsabilité du criminel et celle du
juge dont on dénigre la décision tout
cela avilit l'institution et en
définitive blessé la république pas moi
qui le dit c'est le procureur général
près la cour de cassation
horreur et nous n'en avons jusqu'ici pas
dit autant monsieur le ministre
or monsieur le ministre nous sommes tous
ici attaché aux valeurs fondamentales
qui constituent le socle de notre
république tous le thème de la sécurité
devient un instrument de rupture et de
divisions alors que pour nous il doit
impérativement être un thème de
rassemblement de recherche de
l'équilibré et de sérénité
2 force tranquille avait jeudi en
première lecture
il faut cesser
de justifier l'absence de résultats en
matière de sécurité même si vous nous
annoncez tous les jours de meilleurs par
l'inadéquation des lois alors que
l'essentiel est de mettre les moyens
nécessaires à disposition de ceux qui
sont chargés d'appliquer les
innombrables texte déjà en vigueur
protéger le citoyen ce n'est pas le
surveiller s'en méfier c'est le rassurer
d'abord majoritairement nous ne voterons
pas ce projet de loi parce qu'il
exacerbe des conflits et des sentiments
qui ne saurait rassurer l'immense
majorité de nos concitoyens ni davantage
restaurer la confiance
merci mon cher collègue de suite de
discussions générales la parole est à
eliane ceci pour le groupe crc spg
ces deux coup sur coup ça va faire mal
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues donc à vous entendre on
croirait effectivement que rien ne va
plus dans notre pays mais surtout que
vous n'y êtes pour rien monsieur le
ministre vous ne cessez en effet de nous
asséner que si délinquance il ya c'est
parce que la gauche a été trop laxiste
ou angélique tout en rejetant la faute
sur les complaisants qu'ils soient de
gauche magistrats ou autres voyous en
instance de karchérisation c'est à se
demander monsieur le ministre qui depuis
bientôt dix ans a empiré pléthore de
textes répressifs d'aspiration
sécuritaire à la tête du ministère de
l'intérieur puis de la présidence de la
république avec votre irréductibles
soutien mais vous persistez néanmoins à
ne compter que si la france va mal
et bien c'est à cause du mal nationale
qui est la complaisance en théorie que
vous tentez d'infuser dans les
consciences pour justifier votre
politique ultra-sécuritaire dispense
yeuse inefficace et qui est un échec sur
toute la ligne
cette compétence tous les acteurs
publics et tous les partis politiques
excepté bien évidemment le vôtre est
bien évidemment celui du front national
en aurait été coupable
votre discours se synthétisent aisément
quand il multiplie les raccourcis
puisque les juges ne font pas leur
travail parce que trop complaisant voilà
que vous entendez le faire à leur place
en les cantonnant au rôle de simple
exécutant
si le nombre de primo délinquants
augmente c'est exclusivement de la faute
des parents trop complaisant et qui de
ce fait n'assument pas leurs
responsabilités
ceci n'aurait selon vous
rien à voir avec la saignée opéré dans
l'éducation nationale et ses 66 mille
postes supprimés depuis 2007 vous
incriminez donc les seuls parents
menacés de leur ôter leurs trois après
adorent droits à prestation en leur
faisant signer des papiers qui
contractualise rond leur choix d'être
parents au passage vous rétablissez les
maisons de correction qu'on appellera
pudiquement les centres d'éducation
fermé car si la france va mal c'est sans
doute aussi à cause de la perte de ce
que l'on appelle les valeurs d'antan des
valeurs contestable aux relents souvent
nauséabond et xénophobes que nous ne
voulions pourtant plus voir à la tête de
notre état et pour cause
ainsi toujours selon votre discours bien
ancré si le nombre de crimes et de
délits augmente c'est aussi bien
évidemment de la faute des étrangers
envers qui les dirigeants de gauche sont
montrés encore une fois trop complaisant
vous accusez les migrants de ne rien
comprendre aux principes fondamentaux de
notre république
contrairement bien évidemment au bon
français qui sont eux présumé en être
naturellement apprennent et les autres
doivent s'intégrer pire maintenant
doivent s'assimiler
ce nouveau câble qui a eu un franc
succès sur vauban à l'assemblée
nationale et ce n'est pas fini
avec près de 12000 postes supprimés
depuis 2002 la police est à bout de
souffle alors voulons vous leur offrez
quelques armes de nouvelles technologies
et autres techniques d'investigation en
point jeter un peu de poudre aux yeux à
la police scientifique et technique au
bord de l'implosion en mettant en place
un fonds de soutien qui ne sera sans
doute jamais alimenté et vous décidez
d'installer soixante mille caméras à
l'appui de leurs investigations pour un
taux d'élucidation allant aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre de 1 à 3%
vos équations sont bien trop simpliste
le compte n'y est pas la théorie de la
complaisance ne prend pas et vous
sembler peu prompts à comprendre le sens
de la politique car la politique doit
être défini en vue de maintenir un
équilibre social et ne doit pas
intervenir avec le but de
rompre pour mieux régner poursuivant
votre politique de division entre les
fonctionnaires et les salariés du privé
entre la police et la population entre
les étrangers et les bons français entre
les bons habitants des quartiers
populaires et les villes délinquants
friands de halls d'immeuble entre les
chômeurs et les actifs la france qui se
lève tôt et les profiteurs qui se lève
pas voilà maintenant que vous chercher à
opposer le peuple à la justice qui selon
vous ne rend pas les bonnes décisions
ou plutôt celle que vous souhaiteriez
quelle route
les juges ne font qu'appliquer des
principes généraux du droit mais ne
servent pas votre projet de société
ainsi entendez-vous jugés à leur place
en soutenant des policiers reconnus
coupables sur preuve de delhi pour mieux
laisser place à la vindicte populaire
autrement appelée jury populaire
le comble étant quand même que le
président de la république nous annonce
qu'il entend par cette mesure
vouloir rapprocher la justice du peuple
sauf à vous montrer plaisantins et
celles qui croient pas mais nous nous
demandons bien ce qui anime alors le
dégraissage de la carte judiciaire ce
qui justifie ces déplacements des
juridictions à l'appel dans des
banlieues lointaines dans des locaux
inappropriée et bien souvent fort mal
desservies en termes de transports en
commun
ce faisant vous ne faites que chasser le
peuple que vous présentez des prétendez
défendre ce gouvernement le vôtre ni le
besoin social de justice en supprimant
autant des barreaux de province que de
banlieue obligeant les populations à des
déplacements parfois ubuesques autant
dire que tout cela est infini infiniment
dangereux pour un état de droit il me
semble à moi ut aussi utile de rappeler
ici cette déclaration du procureur nadal
je l'a redit affiché pour la justice une
forme de mépris inspirer à l'opinion des
sentiments bas en instillant de manière
en réalité extravagante la confusion
entre la responsabilité du criminel et
celle du juge dont on dénigre la
décision inscrire au débit des cours et
tribunaux l'altération du lien social
compromis par une multitude de raisons
qui leur sont étrangères tout cela ali
l'institution et en définitive blessé la
république fin de citation je dois dire
que ces propos sont d'une honnêteté que
vous devriez lui envier il ne devrait
pas être permis d'agiter le code pénal
avec si peu de délicatesse
pour notre part nous ne sommes jamais
tomber dans un laxisme qui nierait la
réalité de la délinquance temps nous
sommes attachés à l'idée du contrat
social mais la guerre que vous engagez
n'est pas la nôtre
lors de votre intervention général ici
même en septembre dernier vous aviez
monsieur le ministre cité l'étrange
défaite de marc bloch à l'assemblée
nationale on a entendu monsieur ciotti
dire que je le cite les mesures
contenues dans ce projet de loi était
nécessaire face à une évolution de la
délinquance les délinquants usant de
toutes les techniques pour s'opposer aux
contraintes de la loi et aux moyens
déployés par les forces de l'ordre
justifiant de sa de s'adapter pour
pouvoir soutenir cette guerre de
mouvement contre la délinquance fin de
citation et voilà donc qu'au nom de la
protection de la société contre ses
ennemis présumés
les mesures dérogatoires au droit commun
deviennent la norme la surveillance et
le contrôle social s'étendent
massivement et l'objectif de réinsertion
assigné à chaque peine disparaît j'ai
une question l'état d'urgence serait
t'il décrété vous tenté de faire croire
aux français que votre guerre a été
déclarée en leur nom et au nom de leur
bien-être
cet argument est tout aussi virtuel que
les délinquants nouvelle génération qui
nécessiterait que l'on mène une guerre
de mouvement vous vous efforcez
constamment de commenter des faits
divers tout aussi horrible les uns que
les autres vous légiférer sur cette base
pour me faire comme pour mieux faire
confondre les délits de droit commun
avec les lourdes infractions
vous espérez de toutes ces tactiques de
confusion qu'elle vous permettent non
seulement d'entretenir l'hostilité des
milieux populaires contre cette
catégorie de délinquance mais aussi de
rendre le durcissement de la politique
de répression acceptable mais nos
concitoyens ne sont pas dupes et nous
non plus cette dénonciation constante de
la délinquance du petit peuple
nous quittons l'hémicycle
senna merci à vous d'avoir suivi en
direct le début de l'examen du projet de
loi loppsi 2 la loi d'orientation et de
programmation pour la performance de la
sécurité intérieure devant les sénateurs
brice hortefeux ministre de l'intérieur
a réexpliqué quels étaient les objectifs
de cette loi à savoir assurer la
sécurité des citoyens tout en respectant
leur liberté mais voilà pour les
opposants toujours plus nombreux à ce
texte est bien ce projet de loi loppsi 2
marques au contraire un recul des
libertés individuelles
le gouvernement va donc avoir un examen
difficile de ce texte d'autant que les
sénateurs sont revenus en commission à
la position première du sénat je pense
michel que vous allez revenir donc sur
ces dispositions avec vos invités ce
soir dans le journal de 19h c'est avoue
michel bonne soirée à tous merci
delphine effectivement il y aura un
débat sur la loi loppsi 2 dans quelques
instants
puisqu'il est lors du journal de 19
heures